ten years in the making Avengers
infinity war is the culmination of all
of Marvel's awesome efforts on the big
screen marking the end of many things
and very likely the beginning of even
more things and even though infinity war
is pretty focused on the here and now
rather than the deeper secrets hidden
within the pages of Marvel Comics this
movie didn't disappoint true believers
in fact it's many true to comic scenes
and unexpected callbacks stole the show
here's a spoiler filled look at a few of
the Easter eggs you may have missed in
Avengers infinity war and one more time
in case you missed it massive spoilers
ahead
[Music]
the mark L Tony Stark is probably a few
hundred armors deep when it comes to his
comics counterpart but in the MCU
he's just reached armor number 50 the
mark L this time around he's dropped the
complicated suit up gantry the fancy
suit case and even the Legion of armors
that could just fly around and protect
him from his enemies
Tony's newest armor which he wears in a
small box on his chest is all about
portability and convenience and it's
pulled directly from a couple of comic
sources iron man's skin armor debuted in
2001 and was mostly housed in a small
self-contained unit that could release a
simple liquify form of a suit around his
whole body instantly later Iron Man's
bleeding-edge armor would do something
similar except it formed a complete suit
of armor and it was housed in the
hollows of Tony's bones rather than in
an oversized locket kind of gross but
anything did not have to wear gaudy
glowing jewelry her hey a few extra legs
we've been seeing previews of spider-man
and his fancy new iron spider armor for
months now after he'd first rejected it
at the end of spider and homecoming it's
not far into the movie before he gets
his first feel for the slick new suit
and immediately Stow's away on the trip
to Titan much to Tony's annoyance but
unless you caught one very specific
statue design that was leaked way too
early nobody really expected the suit to
sprout a bunch of extra legs and save
the day that is unless you're familiar
with the iron spider armor in the comics
which has that exact feature while it
initially seemed too outlandish for the
big screen those extra appendages
definitely came in handy and when iron
man can combine his feet to make one
giant rocket foot a couple of extra
spider legs isn't really that weird
anymore Stormbreaker rest in pieces
Mjolnir it was pretty much inevitable
that the guy known for swinging a
mystical weapon would end up getting his
hands on another one pretty quickly
after his iconic hammer was destroyed in
Ragnarok hema unique was made from this
special method from the heart of a dying
star and when I spun it really really
fast it gave me the ability to fly
hammer Thor's new accessory goes by the
name of Stormbreaker loyal comics
readers of course know that names
already been taken by beta ray Bill's
weapon marking
second time that the powerful Thor likes
space horse has been referenced in the
MCU bill is probably out there in the
galaxy somewhere assuming he was
introduced to dust and Thanos his great
cooling of the universe anyway and
Stormbreaker is ready for his arrival
can his first full Marvel Cinematic
Universe appearance be too far behind
fear itself
speaking of Asgardian allies Thor seems
to have pals everywhere Darrell is an
average soda everyday guy so it works
out well
Marvel is once again borrowing parts of
their own previously published comics
for their blockbuster movies having
previously made significant tweaks to
Civil War and Planet Hulk to get them to
the big screen this time fear itself
plays a minor role sure in fear itself
it was Tony Stark visiting the cosmic
drawers to make weapons for the Avengers
to fight the serpent but the general
idea is the same Thor visits the dwarf
treet to get a new Thanos smashing
weapon for better or worse mostly worse
a tour of the galaxy Nadav Alire and
Vermeer aren't just really confusing
crossword puzzle answers they're actual
places in the Marvel Comics universe the
Asgardian arm of Marvel is pretty much
just a wild riff on actual Norse
mythology with slightly more
preposterous muscles so Nadav lair has
real sources and actual historical
documents dating back to the year 1270
which place it as the home of the
dwarves no big questions there Marvel
just uses it pretty much like they found
it warm air on the other hand has never
been that important in Marvel continuity
in the comics it's the home of a bunch
of 16-foot tall dragon like aliens who
feed on planets when Thanos and Gamora
arrived there in infinity war looking
for the soul stone there aren't any
dragons to be found there really isn't
much of anything the significance ends
there it's just a pearl buried deep deep
in Avengers lore but what they did find
on forum here is even more surprising
than what they didn't return of the
skull in a move that almost nobody saw
coming first avenger villain red skull
reappeared in the MCU as the cosmic
guardian of the soul stone having paid
the ultimate price for his search for
cosmic power he's never actually
referred to as Red Skull but he speaks
of his quest for the stones and how it
led him to his imprisonment on vermeer
also he has a red skull it's pretty
obvious
familiar with Thanos's comic-book quest
to make the physical embodiment of death
fall in love with him probably also
notice the similarities between red
school's new all-black
ghoulish form and Marvel's
personification of death it's a great
twist on thanasis comic relationships
and seeing it play out like this here
pretty much guarantees we'll never have
to see a Thanos death makeout scene
everyone wins
cut to ribbons thanassis deal is
generally much more about destruction
than creation but that doesn't mean he's
not one heck of a creative guy diffusing
situations by turning laser blasts into
bubbles and building giant altars to
girls who don't like him in an effort to
show off for death during Infinity
Gauntlet Thanos turns nebula into an
unraveling ribbon and his own brother
starfox into a disjointed stack of
blocks the details are a little
different in the movie but he does the
same thing to mantis and Drax on
knowhere the sentiment is there however
Thanos is powerful weird and ready to
turn anyone into crafting materials at a
moment's notice
Morgan Stark when you're a superhero
there's a 95% chance that your relatives
will either be other super heroes or
villains that you one day have to face
even when you're apparently adopted like
Tony Stark your secret brothers and
cousins will come along and derail your
life such as the case with Morgan Stark
Tony's rarely mentioned cousin Morgan is
an occasional hassle to Tony a guy
involved in mob business who sometimes
attempts to take over Stark Industries
with a super team the stock pile and
like Iron Man he throws on a high-tech
costume but calls himself brass when you
name yourself after the metal that tubas
are made from you're already off to a
pretty crappy start so while it seems
like Tony doesn't even really have any
extended family to worry about in the
MCU it's just a little alarming that
Tony wants to name his unborn kid Morgan
it's just a little like that man naming
his kid Joker
don't do it cauldron of the cosmos
Doctor Strange introduced audiences to
an array of what the mystical side of
the MCU might have to offer
living capes the eye of agamotto and the
wand of watoomb are among the treasures
housed in the New York sanctum infinity
war also confirms the presence of the
cauldron of the cosmos you could destroy
life on us
hitherto on dreamt on did you seriously
just say hitherto hundred of you
seriously leaning on the cauldron of the
cosmos the cauldron is basically dr.
Strange's time TV allowing him to see
into whatever era he wants to muck
around in in Marvel team-up number 112
he uses it to check out a scene twenty
thousand years in the past so it really
doesn't seem to have any limits why he
keeps it as a decoration in his
stairwell is anyone's guess but he's
obviously not happy when Tony Stark
uses it to lean on and while it's not
100% confirmed those bright red magical
ropes that dr. strange was using to
restrain Santos on Titan sure looked
like the crimson bands of cyttorak one
of Strange's most iconic incantations
never-nude infinity war was directed by
the Russo brothers whose previous
credits include directing multiple
episodes of the cult hit comedy show
Arrested Development the Bros had one of
Arrested Development's iconic vehicles
the stair car in the airport battle
scene in civil war they're back again
with the Easter eggs this time dropping
one of the show's actual characters into
the collector's assemblage of treasures
it's a weirdly complicated reference but
if you check out the collectors cases
just as the scene begins you'll spot a
bald blue man and cutoff shorts lounging
in the background look familiar
do you have an audition yet oh no no I'm
not in the group yet no I I'm afraid I
just we might go it's absolutely
ridiculous but we can see why the
collector would want him for his
collection he's one of a kind Stan the
man we're still not completely sure if
Marvel comics mastermind Stan Lee is the
emcee use mail man security guard cosmic
watcher or what but we do know that in
the case of infinity war he's a bus
driver for a bunch of punk kids the film
gets Stan's cameo out of the way super
early just as Peter Parker's senses get
all tingly about the approaching donut
of doom a marvelous ending
infinity war skips the mid-credits scene
pretty much because there's nothing left
to say after Thinnes does his Thanos
thing and turns half of the universe's
living creatures into frosted flakes but
in the film's post-credit scene Nick
Fury puts out a last-second SOS to a
mysterious person who will definitely
have a huge role in the Avengers sequel
it may not be obvious to anyone who
isn't up on their superhero
iconography but it's a teaser for the
upcoming Captain Marvel movie scheduled
for a 2019 release date Captain Marvel
stars brie Larson as Carol Danvers a
pilot who gets incredible abilities
we're talking Thor levels of power maybe
more no wonder MODOK develops a massive
crush on her also can we finally get
MODOK in the MCU please do some kind of
that is a very big hit thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]